[music playing]
Jason, Don, congratulations.
You've made it into the third
round of this competition.
We're sending you back
to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
That weapon is the scissor.
[laughing] Oh god.
Oh god.
Well, good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
[music playing]
Day one, feels good
to be in my own forge.
I've never built armor before.
I've never shaped
sheet metal before.
I need a book, "Armor
for Dummies," you know.
They don't make it.
I looked.
Two billets I'm making right now
are going to be for the blade.
I'm going to twist one one
way, and I'm going to twist
the other one the other way.
I just like the way it looks.
I almost screwed that up
twisted it the same direction.
[music playing]
JASON: I'm going up
against Don from Texas.
Oklahoma always beats Texas.
DON: I'm not really familiar
with a gladiator scissor.
But since it is
armoring, I've been doing
armoring for about 25 years.
I'm sure I can overcome any
challenges that come up for it.
I'm using a coarse
wrought iron combined
with high carbon steel to
make a composite welded blade.
I have no idea what
that came off of.
Just part of my 500
pounds of stuff.
Hey, man, we're Texas.
We're bigger and better,
and our blades are better.
[laughing]
[music playing]
JASON: Today's armor day.
It's the big experiment day,
but seems like all week's
been an experiment.
Yesterday I got a
pattern cut out.
I'm going to try to get
the gauntlet shape today.
I have this big
piece of pipe, so I
can wrap the metal around it.
I'm just trying to
beat [bleep] of it
until it goes
where I want it to.
I'm probably doing this
the hardest [bleep]
possible way there is.
So I've got it lined
up with my marks.
Now I'm going to throw a
little tack weld on each end
and then start getting
the seams closer together.
And that almost looks
like I meant to do it.
[thunder clap]
[music playing]
DON: My whole gauntlet section
is done in three pieces.
The only thing I
have left to do is
to make sure all the parts fit
back together, there's no warps
in there that I can't take out.
Problem I had the first time.
I'm trying to get
the main cone put on.
It's driving me nuts.
There's a slight
warp in it that keeps
catching on the inner layer.
[sighing] Turn it.
[grunting] Damn it.
All right.
One more time.
I'm trying to get
the main cone put on.
There's a slight
warp in it that keeps
catching on the inner layer.
There we go.
Oh.
That was pain.
This is billet number three.
I have a billet of damascus.
I'm not 100% satisfied with it.
I don't think it's going to
look the way that I want.
I'm going to start over with
just uh, some plain steel.
I did not want to be
forging on day four.
I'm going with a W2.
It's going to look good.
It's going to have
to look that I want,
and I'm not going to be
wasting any more time.
I'm starting to get the blade
pretty close to the shape
I want, keeping my
measurements in mind.
Let's get it done.
[music playing]
Even though I don't like
the way the blade looks,
performance-wise, though, I
think it's going to perform
just as good as Don's.
If I lose, I guess
he just got lucky.
Even a blind squirrel get a
nut every once in a while.
[laughing]
All I have left to
do is sharpen the blade
and then do a little
bit of testing.
Wouldn't don't want to
trip while holding this.
That would really suck.
I want to make sure
nothing's going
to rattle loose when the judges
start hitting stuff with it.
That would hurt.
Now the final test.
It rubs on a knuckle slightly,
but you know, to be honest,
I didn't even notice
that until afterwards
because I was just having
too much fun swinging
and cutting things with it.
DAVID: All right gentlemen,
this is the sharpness test.
To test the sharpness
of your edge,
I'm going to attack our
sandman here several times,
see how they do.
Jason, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
- Yes, sir.
DAVID: All right.
[music playing]
[laughing] All right.
The handle feels
really good in my hand,
but the shape of
your blade not being
as deep a crescent made
it a little bit more
difficult to slash.
All in all, solid and
it's got a good look.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, Don.
You ready?
I'm ready.
[music playing]
Don, I like the way this is
set up, tighter around the arm.
But right here at
my hand, my knuckle
is just pounding into the side.
You can see it slashed
pretty easily on the arm,
and then on the forward punch,
didn't quite get the slash
that I was looking for.
I'm feeling a little nervous.
It didn't perform like I wanted.
I think Jason had the edge here.
His was a more comfortable
fit across the hand.
All in all,
though, did the job.
Thank you.
DAVID: Next up, I'll
give you to Doug.
Bladesmiths, this
is a kill test.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your scissor
and I will deliver killing
blows on this ballistics dummy.
Jason, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
[laughing]
First up, the minute I put
my hand in, your handle--
It's not directly in line
with my fist, so slightly off.
But as you can see, I can
still wield the weapon.
The laceration was deep
into this cavity right here,
so you've got a
very sharp blade.
The hook you have penetrated
right into the heart
on the back hand draw.
It lacerates and cuts
everything out and disembowel
this ballistics dummy.
Your weapon, sir, will kill.
Good job, sir.
Thank you.
Don, your turn.
Let's have some fun.
DOUG: Let's do this.
[music playing]
DON: [laughing]
Good.
DOUG: Don, let's talk
about your weapon.
What I like about your
weapon is that it's
in line with the handle.
On the initial cut here, it
lacerated right through there.
And in this back
hand hook, your edge
is deep to go in here and
right into that cavity.
Your weapon will kill.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen,
this is the strength test.
Now the scissor was used
in gladiatorial combat
for both attack and defense.
Now to test the strength and
durability of your weapon,
we will clamp them into
our mechanical device here.
The blade's going to come down
and strike the armored cuff
of your weapon twice, and then
your weapon is going to be
launched into this breastplate.
Jason, I've already
got yours strapped in,
so are you ready to go?
Let's do it.
DAVID: OK.
[music playing]
Just the slightest roll.
It's not deformed
beyond being sharp.
And then you can see where the
sword came down and hit it,
caused a bit of deformation.
And then I think we were pushed
just a little further offline.
It-- Right in here,
it looks like it
kind of waffled just a bit.
But everything is still
tight, still sharp.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
So Don, you're ready?
I'm ready.
[music playing]
So looking at this, I
can I'm having a hard time
finding where the
sword hit it, and
there's one teeny little mark.
Blade's still tight, and that
edge is still a razor blade.
There's no rolling at all.
Very well done.
It's nice.
Thank you.
[music playing]
Bladesmiths,
you've worked very
hard to recreate
weapons that we've never
seen here in the forge before.
However, in this competition,
there can only be
one "Forged in Fire" champion.
And that champion is Don.
Congratulations, you are the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Jason, unfortunately your
blade did not make the cut.
David Baker will explain.
Jason, what this came down
to was the strength test.
As a gladiator's weapon,
it's got to be strong.
That rolled edge
and the deformation
you took from the
hit on the cuff?
Well that's why we're
sending you home.
Jason please surrender
to your scissor.
JASON: I spent five
days making something
I've never made before.
I went up against a guy who
builds armor quite often.
I held my own against him.
I'm pretty proud of that fact.
I loved every minute
of this experience.
Don, congratulations, you are
the "Forged in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
that check for 10 grand.
How do you feel right now?
Man, I feel fantastic.
It feels great to be a
"Forged in Fire" champion.
$10,000.
I'd like to get something
nice for my wife.
We kind of had a
little fun, you know,
making jokes at each other
about Texas versus Oklahoma.
Yeah, I'm glad to see
Texas came out on top.
[laughing] Woo!